[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a science fiction action film
called fortress spoilers ahead watch out
and take care
[Music]
the movie begins in futuristic canada
where the government has banned the
birth of a second child to control the
population no one is allowed to give
birth to more than one child even if the
first one dies at the heavily guarded
canada united states border station an
automated voice requests everyone to
take their personal belongings to the
inspection office former army officer
john henry brennik and his wife karen
brennick are in a car about to be
inspected the couple seems to be nervous
about the check when karen moves her arm
a magnetic vest that she is wearing
inside her overcoat is visible turns out
that karen is pregnant and they are
going to vancouver to give birth to
their second child after the first child
is born the government ties the female's
tube however karen got lucky and got
pregnant again hence the magnetic vest
is to cover her pregnancy when they are
at the inspection center the soldiers
order them to get out of the car with
their belongings while a soldier checks
karen's bag a girl in front of them gets
arrested for being pregnant but as karen
walks through the scanning machine the
magnetic vest stops it from alerting the
guards the couple is safely outside but
one guard approaches them and notices
the magnetic vest on karen an alarm
starts to ring and the soldiers attack
them jon manages to fight them and runs
away with karen to cross the bridge as
the soldiers pursue them jon asks karen
to run away without him and she
reluctantly agrees jon is soon arrested
but karen manages to flee in the
following scene we see jon and other
prisoners like him in a vehicle being
taken to a prison called the fortress
it is a privately owned maximum-security
prison offered by the mental corporation
the fortress lies in the middle of a
massive desert and escaping from the
prison is impossible they get inside the
facility and the guards make them strip
naked a voice in the background welcomes
the prisoners to the fortress and
introduces himself as director poe the
prisoners are then brought to a room
where everyone is fitted with a
psychological security intelligence
system the system is fitted into their
intestine and is triggered when anyone
breaks the prison's rules the process is
called intestination poe announces that
after the implantation of the technology
the prisoners who cross the yellow line
on the floor will be induced with
extreme pain in their abdomen and the
ones who cross the red line will die
instantly one of the inmates gets
nervous and crosses the yellow line as
soon as he does he falls down in pain he
accidentally crosses the red line too
the man's stomach starts to bloat and
eventually bursts others are put into an
elevator that goes underground it is
revealed that the prison is 30 stories
underground john and a fellow inmate
named nino gomez are let off on a floor
they are greeted by a monitoring device
called the z10 which takes them to a
crowded prison cell one of the inmates
named stiggs yells at zed claiming that
the cell already has too many people but
zed instead threatens to intestinate him
the cells have a laser beam that stops
inmates from going out when not needed
jon introduces himself to another inmate
named d-day as they are about to fall
asleep the third inmate named abraham
tells jon to not dream
after everyone is asleep zed comes to
inspect the prisoners it scans jon's
face and goes into his dream jon is
dreaming about him making love to karen
somewhere else in the monitoring room
the prisoner's director poe watches
john's dream and grows an infatuation
with karen he reminds jon dreaming is an
unauthorized thought process that is not
allowed in the facility and wakes him up
sharp pain in his abdomen makes him
struggle suggesting that he has been
intestinated the following day the
inmates are made to work in underground
construction
a homosexual inmate named maddox
sexually assaults nino jon comes to his
rescue and fights maddox zed stops the
commotion by triggering the device in
their abdomen later all three of them
are kept in a tiny laser cell and asked
who started the fight nino is too scared
of maddox to tell the truth to save nino
john lies that he himself started the
fight he is then taken to poe's office
where abraham is shaving poe's beard poe
shows john a live video of karen
showering as it turns out she was
arrested after jon and brought to prison
as well
poe intestinates karen and john making
them whimper in pain as his punishment
later abraham tells jon that floors a
and b are the women's quarters hence
karen might be there too then we see
karen in her cell talking to a fellow
pregnant girl as her stomach starts to
hurt two guards take her away karen
realizes that the facility does
something with their newborn children in
the men's quarter maddox picks a fight
with jon the men get into an intense
battle as everyone in the facility
watches them along with poe from his
cabin karen sees her husband from her
floor and is surprised both the parties
are bloodied when jon pushes maddox off
the edge but he hangs on to it
poe orders jon to finish off maddox but
jon instead helps him poe takes the
matter into his own hands and uses a
weapon to kill maddox that blows up his
whole stomach creating a hole in it jon
finds maddox's abdomen device on the
floor and secretly hands it to nino
before being taken away by the guards in
the following scene karen walks into a
room where jon is suspended in a massive
machine called the mind wipe chamber poe
has sent her to ask jon to cooperate
with them they talk for a while but the
guards drag her out soon after the
machine starts to move along with jon
making him hallucinate this is his
punishment for not obeying director
poe's order to kill maddox john's brain
slowly starts to break down as he sees
his time at the military his wedding day
and so on after three days poe invites
karen to his chamber he is surprised
that jon has lasted this long as the
maximum someone has ever lasted on the
machine is an hour he offers karen to
let jon free if she stays with him at
his chamber as his companion with no
choice left karen agrees when jon
returns to his cell he is completely
brain dead he doesn't talk to anyone and
has become completely numb to pain karen
has started to live with poe one night
she wakes up to see poe in a chair
attached to several wires as it turns
out he was modified to be an advanced
human he doesn't sleep or eat but
intake's amino acids once a month the
same happens with all the children born
in the prison they go through several
procedures to be turned into advanced
humans so that one day mankind can be
free of overpopulation and starvation
poe is one of the first babies to be
experimented upon karen is shocked by
the information
four months pass and jon has still not
recovered abraham tells him that karen's
belly is finally showing and his baby
will be born into the world soon john
doesn't react but sheds a single tear
that night karen tricks poe into
drinking alcohol which makes him pass
out she uses the control panel to
control jon's dream in which she sees
the kid version of john trapped in a pit
she brings him back out of the pit
bringing the real john back into
consciousness his inmate friends are
shocked and happy to have him back john
asks abraham to help him escape the
prison with karen abraham is skeptical
but agrees to do it for john anyway
abraham tells karen about jon's recovery
she is over the moon about her plan
working she claims that she can help him
with the escape and starts to devise a
plan later nino hands john the device he
had gotten from maddox's body their
inmate friend d-day used to be a
computer geek before coming to prison he
offers to take the device apart and
study it next we see karen steal a
diamond-like holographic lens from poe's
cabin she almost gets caught but manages
to hide the device inside her mouth she
hands the device to abraham the
following day and asks him to give it to
john abraham doesn't want to get in
trouble but accepts doing it as a favor
the guys use the cell's protective laser
beams to trigger the lens and look at
the hologram of the facility they find
that there is a way out through the
construction site the following morning
abraham puts the lens back in poe's
cabin poe asks karen to divorce jon and
marry him he claims he will treat the
child as his own and even promises to
let jon go free karen accepts the offer
for her husband and child meanwhile
d-day figures out how the intestinate
device works the device is magnetic and
can be used to bring out the devices
from other bodies they try the procedure
and are surprised when it works they get
all of their intestinate devices out
the following day poe is alerted by zed
to look through the security camera
footage where he sees karen stealing the
lens and abraham putting it back he is
angered to see he has been betrayed but
zed informs him that he has been
dismissed because of his carelessness
meanwhile the boys put their plan into
action they attach their intestinate
devices to a metal pipe in the
construction area and pose as if they
are fighting as zed finds out about the
fight it triggers the intestinates
causing them to explode this creates a
way for them to escape through the pipe
but poe activates the steam valves and
sends hot gas into the pipes to keep
them trapped he also activates the
strike clones who start firing at the
group from inside the facility they are
stuck in the pipe now one of the inmates
sticks panics and tries to go into the
facility again but the clones shoot him
dead
meanwhile abraham approaches karen at
the facility but before they can do
anything poe finds them he kills abraham
and makes some soldiers take karen to
turn her baby into an advanced human
like him
meanwhile the guys manage to kill one of
the clones and find out that he is an
advanced human as well john takes his
gun and attacks the other clones they
get inside the facility while battling
the clones in the end they manage to get
on top of an elevator-like machine that
lifts them up everyone in the prison
cheers for them when they see them
escaping
they finally reach poe's chamber and
demand to meet karen the screen shows
the doctors trying to extract her baby
john threatens poe to cease the delivery
but since he has been dismissed the
system doesn't take his command one of
the killing devices recognizes the guys
and tries to shoot them but they quickly
dodge it making poe its victim after
poe's death d-day gets on the control
panel and tries to stop the doctors from
performing the procedure on karen but
before he can complete the process a
clone shoots him john manages to kill
the clone and an injured d-day disables
the whole facility's electrical system
with his final strength the doctors stop
the procedure for the time being the
security system fails and every prisoner
starts running away john and nino are
the only survivors they go to look for
karen and take her away from the doctors
the three get into a vehicle and finally
drive away from the facility they only
stop when they cross the border and
reach mexico karen is about to give
birth in a shed when the vehicle they
drove in starts to move on its own as it
turns out it is still being controlled
by the facility it hits nino and kills
him
jon goes out to fight the vehicle as
karen is in labor inside the shed john
attacks the vehicle with the weapon from
earlier and explodes it but the vehicle
strikes the shed and karen is buried in
its remains a distressed john looks for
his wife and finds her safe nearby she
has a newborn baby in her hands the
movie ends as the two look at their kid
in fascination
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching